oh god no I don't want to click it I'm
not gonna click it when you click it if
they say no to you I say we say no to
them they don't want my baby they're
stupid when I became a dad I made a
choice to support my daughter's dreams
you don't have enough money it says
right here you have four hundred and one
thousand dollars you missed it that says
you have a 401k account Alex thinks we
can afford tuition and we can't we don't
lie that's what parents do cuz otherwise
the kids are gonna realize it we don't
know what we're doing
welcome I have a way for you guys to
make four years tuition in one month
underground casino seems to check out do
this man you're 40 years old and you go
to jail for twenty years how old are you
when you get out 90 no 100 honey if I
have some scratch paper I can figure it
out you want to make money like Vegas
you gotta look like Vegas we've got a
nail salon massages you're never gonna
believe what's in this next room is it a
strip club
what's up with that kid the kids 11 he's
a fantastic DJ drop that beat
your mother and I will be working late
every night you don't feel like you're
lying
we love you so much we're so proud of
you but you need to shut up what did you
just say so hard being a parent
something fishy going on with those
three friends fighting for casino we
ever heard a fight mate martha more
pretty good in there both take the same
MMA class at the Y no there tell you I
feel like a badass bitch I'm not going
to tell my daughter she can't go to
college so we resorted to a life of
crime
guys to get problems we gotta send a
message like De Niro and Casino you
think you can cheat us what are you guys
gonna do about it anyway
I'm so scared
tell your friends if they mess with us
you're gonna get